where did you post the casting notice
for amateur so we actually had a casting
director Matthew wolf and a casting
associate Celia Celia ow on this short
I'm used to doing casting myself and
posting it on you know backstage and
actors access and but you know one of
the things when we were trying to get
this short made quickly and I think as
soon as you're you know trying to
compress a timeline the best thing you
can do is let other people do their job
so mmm that's a question for them I did
have some friends on Facebook say hey I
just saw posting that for something that
you're directing on my actors feed and
but I didn't you know honestly I didn't
know where that was my job was just as
director to show up and you know not to
see who could nail a role but then how
they take direction and take him off in
a few different directions and from
there the from there it was a matter of
rehearsal you know I think the nice
thing about casting is short is that
someone can go read the entire piece and
it and know the arc and know what's
coming so that they come in and not just
reading a scene context-free so you
really you know with a nine page script
you really get a sense of who grasps the
character but you know do they
understand the complexities and can they
make the turn at the end so that was
nice to be able to you know have that
and have actors come in and just
completely get the performance and get
the character you know felt great as the
screenwriter and then as a director we
did a rehearsal at my apartment the day
before the shoot which was really was
really what allowed us to you know on
the day be making small tweaks as
opposed to having do a global redo and
say okay you know this scene is way to
blank and we need to get on target
during you know why you're burning
through money on the set so you know the
short being very there's you know very
definite arcs in each character there's
a very definite power dynamic that is
shifting and to be able to rehearse and
sort of say okay you know what your
level of confidence is at this point and
I haven't
knowing where it's going and to sort of
break down each individual scene and
have that tone already I have all of us
be on the same page already going into
the day is really what allowed us to you
know achieve what we achieve given the
page count the number of steps we were
doing you in and what is essentially
except for the last thing you know one
day shoot
you